and dailyvee is back wait it's back
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
what i did yesterday yeah so woke up
yesterday and it was an exciting day
because we were obviously revealing
series 2b friends something we've been
working on for four to five six seven
eight months so you have a perspective
pigeon let's go do you understand how
unprecedented this is this is
unprecedented so huge culmination of
course it landed on a travel day which
is rare for me these days but i said yes
to puerto rico because i knew a lot of
my friends had moved here gave a speech
thought i was really in a fun mindset
the reason i'm so out there on social is
because it's hard to be so out there and
social
most people can't deal with the heat
they don't like when somebody says
they're ugly or stupid or full of [ __ ]
or a scam artist or they suck or they're
overrated
people don't like that
i don't care not because i'm so cool
it's because that person doesn't know me
how can i possibly be upset when
sallypants47 is having a bad day
sallypants47 is having a bad day and
decides to take it out on me because i
look too happy i'm not mad at hate i'm
compassionate to hate but at the same
token
knock on wood for me
90 of my comments are just little goat
emojis
and that requires even more tune out you
have to cut out the noise all of it
especially the positive noise because
when you get high on your own supply
it's a wrap
were a high schooler going into the job
market today what industry would you go
into whether it's crypto
is that predicated on you trying to
maximize your financial impact like i
would go into something that would
inform me there's a really fun question
i get from you characters which is like
the people i love the most like the
youngsters to me that's a really tough
question because it's always framed in
the way you just did it which is binary
based on where is their financial
opportunity meanwhile i'm 46 now and for
the last 20 years i've been nothing but
around people who do real estate and
wall street in manhattan
and want to jump out [ __ ] windows
because they hate it so much the only
reason they do it is to make 697 000 a
year to buy cars and clothes to cover up
their pain so i have no interest in
telling you to do that you should be
like his mom and go to oregon and not
have electricity if that makes you happy
i meant what i said
go after the [ __ ] that makes you most
happy you can always get into money
later
if you can figure out making money in
something you [ __ ] love
it's [ __ ] everything if it's just
money you'll burn out if it's just you
know just passions way better than just
money but if you figure out how to
[ __ ] make the [ __ ] you love work it's
[ __ ] game changing
so we caught those vibes stayed super
hype all day about the v friend series
two it was fun to watch the gang here
d.o drock no dustin get excited about
which characters did they get drock was
a hater some guy pulled two black cats
at a 14. he pulled two black cats
it's annoying t-rock says
what a hater
he's a hater wanted to do uh logan's
podcast talking about that for a while
so got to the podcast where i'll talk
about how it's nice to do a long podcast
have a time
got a lot of depth even just hanging
with you that little bit in new york
that last round like
you
are literally always working and i asked
you like when do you have fun
how do you balance that work and play
life i don't think anybody can work
hard hard
unless they like it
i was the least hard
working student in the history of this
[ __ ] country i was selling lemonade
and shoveling snow and washing cars and
selling baseball cards
every day of my childhood or every other
day in between playing sports because it
was more fun for me than anything else i
could do so for me
it's really easy and i see it in others
what's awesome now with the internet is
entrepreneurship is so much more
creative
i think without the creative lens you
wouldn't have worked as hard if it was
like pure entrepreneur i was like pure
like i'm a salesman i like it i like the
sales part i like the operations part so
i have big companies i like to operate
um but now there's so many options for
the people that are watching that like
they're they don't like their job and
like that's just part of like making a
binary decision of are you willing to
risk the upfront for the long-term
happiness most people are stuck because
they live
within the means of their salary and
they've got debt and they're like stuck
in a hamster wheel and the only way to
get out is to downgrade your optics
worst car worse apartment worse year or
two or three in your trips and your
nightlife and i'm very empathetic that
for a lot of people they can't make that
move hang that out drove back hang out
with the boys a little bit ate some late
night food shot the [ __ ]
talked to aj bunch during the day i mean
i love to celebrate these moments all in
all good stuff a couple weeks here we
got vcon coming up just loaded with
popular culture the culture of nft that
content's going to be bananas and then
hopefully after that you know between v2
and that and q1 getting the
vayner x world set up maybe we can take
a little breath probably not
then get very focused on the back half
of the year
to completely annihilate it both on the
gift goat airdrop nfts i'm very focused
on but even more importantly character
development that rare robot song
let's pop that overlay give me a second
i want to enjoy it
[Music]
running on positive energy
and keeping it clear
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna see a lot of content like
that you're gonna get to know these
characters in a real way
what's flex and fox up to adaptable
alien like
we need to teach people adaptability
people are not comfortable in their own
skin thus they're unable to be
chameleons in every situation thus they
become awkward and insecure and it
perpetuates so we didn't nip that in the
bud early so a lot of character
development
nice and early here in puerto rico on
the way the airport the car broke down
and so
new cars coming back it was time to film
this
i like this little
time we had together let's do it again
see ya
oh yeah
subscribe
like comment all that stuff that gives
uh drock the short-term endorphin hits
he needs badly
well i don't know i was done and you're
like can you do that i'm like yeah okay
fine you need you need the app needs the
action and uh just really really excited
to be back with dailyvee it won't be the
dailyvee that we invented years ago
where it's daily and
and daily but we're gonna film hopefully
sometimes five days a week some days
some days zero days a week
and everything in between
uh dailyvee's back
like a [ __ ]
[Music]